hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about seven ways to get 10,000
YouTube views alright so YouTube
recently came out with a new policy that
if your channel did not have at least
10,000 lifetime YouTube views on your
channel then you would not get any
monetization from Adsense on your
channel once you cross 10,000 views then
you can start making money and so today
I want to share with you my seven ways
on how to get that first 10,000 views
for your channel if those of you who've
already hit the 10,000 views these
strategies will help you to we number
one is making video I'm a trending topic
just kind of like what I'm doing with
this video right now I'm eating my own
dog food this is a topic that a lot of
people are talking about the try to
figure out how do I get my first 10,000
views and so what am i doing making a
video about something that's newsworthy
that people are talking about to help
drive more traffic and awareness on
these videos in general this was not a
strategy that I usually do most of my
content is evergreen content meaning if
you watch my videos from five years ago
it's still relevant it's still
applicable it's still helpful to you
today but it's not the strategy that
every youtuber needs to go down every
content creator needs to go down as well
so I've been looking at is there
anything in the news that you want to
talk about whether it's politics whether
it's business whether it's your local
economy whatever it is is there
something newsworthy that you have an
opinion on that you want to share when I
was first starting with my agent he was
always coaching me to say I want you to
take a powerful position on this thing
that is happening in this political
scene or that this company did this
thing and it was really hard for me
because I don't really care I don't
really have strong opinions on politics
and what else was happening in the news
I don't really follow pop culture a lot
of these things that people are
concerned about I don't really care
about most of the newsworthy buzz worthy
things and so I couldn't create content
around it but it doesn't mean that you
can't and it's a powerful way to help
you get your first 10,000 fees
[Music]
we're number two is to create a reaction
video if you look at a video that is
already having a lot of success it's
easy to piggyback off of that video by
making a similar one with your own
thoughts your own opinions so for
example if the channel put out a video
about the top 7 marketing books for
entrepreneurs if you had a thought on
that you want to share your list of
books for entrepreneurs you can make a
video with the same topics the top 7
books for entrepreneurs in marketing and
then you can share your thoughts right
it's not just copying what somebody else
did from the topic point of view but
adding more context and Clarry around
your opinions of it so the goal is when
somebody watches that video yours is
going to be the next one that pops up
right afterwards so if you use a similar
title you use some of the same words in
the description you use similar tags
then you're likely to show up after that
first video just make sure again that
you're adding value you're adding some
context there you're at it till 10 is
worth watching you have something that
you want to add your own opinion to and
you're not just trying to piggyback off
of somebody for the wrong reasons
it has to still be a good quality video
but if you can create a good reaction
video or good piggybacking video then
it's much easier to get those initial
views coming into your channel way
number three is update your social media
BIOS in most social media platforms you
have an opportunity to put a link where
is that link going what you want to do
is try to get as much traffic and much
attention going to your YouTube channel
as possible you want to hit that 10,000
views as quickly as possible and so
there's actually a cool tool out of -
buddy - but is the tool that I use I
don't know if this is part of the free
version or not I'm not associated with
the company apart from being a happy
user they have an option to have a link
to your most recent YouTube video and so
right now that's the bio for my Twitter
account it's the bio for my Instagram
account
it's a bio on my Facebook account I
don't think it's LinkedIn I got to
update my LinkedIn account so anytime
somebody goes to see my social media
they see that link they can click on it
it'll take them to my most recent video
even if you don't do that you can lead
them to a single video that you really
want to promote or you can lead them to
your channel that you really want to
promote having that link because most
you get one link put it in there so that
anytime somebody checks you on social
media they're also going to check out
your YouTube videos as a side note you
can also put it in your emails at the
bottom of my emails and every signature
it'll say here's a link to my latest
video so anytime you're sending email
out to somebody
you put it as a PS just have it as
default in your signature you're sending
out emails people like it so I'm going
to click through and you get more views
on your channel number four is do some
collabs one of the best way to grow a
channel is to partner up and collaborate
with somebody who already has an
audience and channel of their own does
it have to be a massive channel but they
have a similar size channel or maybe
slightly bigger than yours and you're
giving them value that they could come
out to their audience you have a video
on their channel now people going to
learn about you they're going to want to
say hey who's that person what's your
channel let me check them out and
they're going to funnel your way some of
the first clubs that I did was with
youtubers Tim Schmoyer and Derral Eve's
I've done four collabs with standalone
videos to think with Tim I was part of
his YouTube entrepreneur series I ran
for 12 episodes Derral I think we did
one video together it was just basically
finding ways that I could add value to
their audience at the time they both had
bigger audiences than I did and so
really helped me get some initial
traffic and views on my channel I've
gone on to do a lot more collaborations
we've had guests come on my channel I've
been on other people's channels I did a
series with Brian Tracy the sales and
time management expert where we did the
top ten rules for entrepreneur or
something like that and he had five on
his channel
I had five on my channel at the end of
our videos we both said go check out the
other vs. channel to see the other five
rules so those kinds of things coming up
with creative ways to market yourself
and work with other YouTube creators
ideally somewhat in the same space so
they have an audience that is related to
your audience it's kind of the same base
from that they would want to then check
you out if I look at Tim's audience
Darryl's audience as an example their
audience are all youtubers people who
only want to build an income base off of
youtube but they're all entrepreneurs so
it's a sub segment of my audience as
well and so those collaborations really
did some work so look at who is already
in your market who's doing videos for an
audience at a similar to yours and how
can you find a way to work
together and give them value we number
five is make a one word video now you
may know what your one word is you may
know what you're all about you may
understand what you're you know core
value is you may not know you can check
out the book if you want to even if you
can't get it down to one word just
understanding why you're here it's
making a why video what is this channel
all about why is it so important and not
just a not from a mental point of view
not from here's why you need to
subscribe to my channel nobody really
cares about those videos but but from
the heart something coming out that you
have made that you just think is awesome
the video that helped explode my channel
the first video that really took off and
got a hundred thousand views in the
first month and now is that two million
views was believed it was a video belt
believe when I watched it like yes
that's what it's about that's what I
want people to feel when they come and
visit my channel that's what I want
entrepreneurs to look at on a regular
basis and feel every day as they bring
that to their business so I passionate
why video for what you're doing here why
is this so important to you something
that when you watch it it gets your
blood excited say yes that's it that's
the feeling I want people to feel you
can pour that kind of love and energy
into making that kind of heroic video
then you have a good chance of getting
your first 10k views we number six is
getting your friends to help you have
friends let them know about your channel
let them know about your mission let the
know you're trying to do that let them
know you're trying to get the 10k views
send them the videos that you feel are
most relevant to them that they would
enjoy they find some value at the daming
want to share and help other people with
as well I still use this strategy as an
example when I was trying to get
interviews for your one word I
interviewed the honest company and to
get in the door I made a video on it and
then I asked people to leave comments on
the video to show that there was
engagement in action and then I could
take that to the honest company say hey
look people are curious people want to
hear from you however we set up a
meeting so that I can have you in my
blog and so where I got the most results
from that was actually my Facebook
friends I sent it to my YouTube audience
I sent out a couple newsletters to my
newsletter list and said hey guys can
you
what me in there too is what I'm trying
to do can you please leave a comment on
this video but I got the best results
from my Facebook friends where went down
my entire list and I had a message and
it said dear whoever I'm trying to do
this
can you please support me watch this
video leave a comment on it it really
really really mean a lot to me that was
the highest response rate and it led to
the most number of comments on that
video and so I wouldn't underestimate
your friends I look at the people who
you hang out with doesn't have to be
your close friends but friends of
friends people who you you know they
would recognize your name if you went
off and asked them for a favor and
sharing the mission sharing the Y seeing
like I'm trying to get my channel 10,000
views that really helped me start
monetizing my channels is really super
helpful important to me or there's one
video that you're really trying to get
the attention of somebody with and your
support of commenting or sharing really
really help me if it's if it feels like
a heartfelt message people want to
support other people's dreams and
especially if it's only of you it's only
a comment you're not asking somebody to
give you money for then it can really
help get that channel to where you want
to go so get your friends involved and
ask for help and we number 7 to get
10,000 views on your channel is to make
a listicle video people like list of the
videos what's a listicle video this i'm
eat my own dog food again right 7 ways
to do something whatever idea you have
whatever your message is whatever level
of expertise you have you can make a top
10 list the top 7 list the top 8 ways
the top 9 secrets making a listicle
video helps make it easy for people to
digest and when people see numbers in a
video they're much more likely to click
through for whatever reason so try to
take that extra cheese that you have
those opinions that you have and form it
in a list and make that video it's much
more likely to stand out and secrete so
those are my seven ways to get your
first 10,000 views on your channel I'd
love to know what did you think what
strategy is your favorite that you're
going to now immediately apply on your
channel do you have an 8 9 10 that you
want to add to the list as well
leave it down the comments below I'm
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout-out to Charles bond
since Charles thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and the fun videos that you put
together
on your channel I really really
appreciate the support man and I'm glad
you enjoyed the book so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love
I'll see you soon